It's time to expose the ingernexs
prostate cuff configmat and
[INAUDIBLE] assert secrets to
secure monolith pot at runtime.
Examine the secure monolith
pocket figuration file.
This is our first multi-container pod.
You'll see that we have the nginx and
monolith containers in here.
These containers are deployed
in the same pod because they
depend on each other.
We've talked about the monolith before.
So let's focus on nginx.
There are two things
interesting to note here.
One, we've added a graceful
shutdown to the container by
adding a life cycle hook.
So on shutdown,
we want to run that command.
This will allow ingernex to do the right
thing, handle all remaining traffic and
shutdown cleanly.
Two, at the bottom of our
pod configuration file.
You'll see we added
corresponding volumes.
So that the internet's container Can
now access our secrets and configs.
Create the secure model
of pod using kubectl.
If we examine the secure-monolith pod,
we'll notice that it has two
containers running inside of it now.
Now that the secure-monolith
pod is up and
running we can access it using
kubectl port-forward command.
In a second terminal,
let's forward local port 10443 to
443 of the secure mine with pod.
Remember, 443 is what our Internet's
container is listening on.
Use a curl command to test the http
end point in another terminal.
And now we get a response
back from the server.
Over the secure https connection.
We can use the kuectl command to verify
traffic to the Internet container on
the secure monolith part.
The kubernetes ttl port
forwarding command is great for
testing pods directly.
But in production,
you want to expose pod using services.